towns which were upon disbelief
and oppression were destroyed
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
After which we brought up
another town in their stead, in
their place. This verse here
articulates to us the majority
of those who were sent
messengers by Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. When we see that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
the Quran speaks about
destroying an entire village
This is a people whom a
messenger was sent to and Allah
destroyed them for their
transgressions.
an entire people the entirety
of a city's citizenry was
destroyed by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. This will be as a
result of their disbelief. As a
result of their rejection of
their messengers. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has sent to
every people a messenger. To
every people a messenger. And
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
promised that none will be
punished by Allah. Until a is
received by them. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
We would never punish anyone
until we send a messenger to
them. Doesn't mean that every
single person receives a
messenger from Allah. Rather it
means every people will receive
a messenger and all of the
people that enter the hellfire
will receive the message.
Clearly.
Those who die prior to
receiving this message will
receive it in the hereafter.
They will receive it an
environment of acceptance or
rejecting, rejection.
and whatever truth they follow
during their lives that they
were aware of. Just because a
person or a people have not
believed in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
the correct way, in a pristine
way, doesn't mean that they
don't have any part or element
of the truth with them. people
in general know that. stealing
is wrong. Murder is wrong, you
know, oppression, lying,
etcetera. That these things are
wrong. In all religions, in all
faiths, in all beliefs. and so
when a person knows that these
things are wrong,
or by remnants of the messages
of the messengers who have come
before them and they reject
this wrong, that counts against
them. that is counted against
them. because a person is
rejecting an element of the
truth However, in order for
this decision to be made
completely clear, a person must
receive the message of the
prophets and messengers.
and if a person rejects that
message, then and they reject
that message when it was
presented clearly to them and
it has punctured the emotional
barrier that they have around
them as the message of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala does. So
eloquently, when that rejection
takes place, this is when a
person becomes eligible for the
anger law and the punishment of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us that not only did he destroy
these people but he brought up
a people to replace them. and
this articulates to us how
meaningless our lives are and
how meaningless we are to Allah
if we do not fulfill what we
have been commanded by We have
no meaning. Without the
commands of Allah, the
prohibitions of Allah. And we
have no stature with Allah. If
we do not fulfill his
commandments. Rather our worth
and our value is gauged by our
obedience to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And authored by Imam Al
Bukhari.
Al Imam collected a narration
on the authority of Abdullah
that the prophet said
[Silence]
placed in one side of a scale
and in the opposite side, would
outweigh them all. What does
this mean? This means that the
heavens and the earth and all
that is in between they get
their value from Allah.
Without we have no value with
Allah. And with we may reach
our full potential of value
with Allah. So Allah tells us
that he destroyed them and he
brought up a people to take
their place as if they never
existed.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
Grant
us physician and stature
with him
he says that when he destroyed
these people He says, and when
they had a, when they began to
feel our punishment, suddenly,
they began to run. What does
this mean? Suddenly, they began
to run. Meaning, running from
the punishment of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. physically
and figuratively physically
running from the punishment of
Allah and figuratively. Running
from the punishment of Allah in
the form of repentance. But
repentance at this point is too
little, too late. Everybody
repents when they feel pain.
Everyone That's not unique
What's unique is a person who
repents when they feel
pleasure. Repent in times of
ease. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
as a kind of mockery of these
people and their state of being
That's when they feel they need
Allah, they turn to him in
repentance but when they are
under the illusion and
misdirection, of the material
world, that they are
independent and don't need
Allah, they forget him and
worship other than he. He says,
do not run. And return to your
luxuries. That you were in. And
your homes
so that you may go back to
being asked. Asked here means
that they were of high stature
in the public eye. And people
would come to them with their
issues. We need this. We need
that. Whether they're being
asked for money or this is this
gives a person a feeling of
power. human beings naturally
power and comfort and they
tend towards these things. They
don't only want to feel
comfortable but they want to
see others feel in need of
them. and less comfortable than
themselves It makes them feel
good that they're being asked
for money and help. They don't
want people to have what they
have. They want to be in a
position to be asked and they
won't give unless they're
asked. Even if they know
someone is in need. So Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala here is
saying Now, you are fleeing
from your homes. Don't flee.
Come back. Go back to your
homes. Return to your luxurious
homes and the luxuries you were
in. Those luxuries that led you
astray, led you to believe that
you were not in need of Allah.
Why are you running from them
now? They are not intrinsically
valuable because when
punishment takes place in them,
you run from them. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says that
they are pleased revolve around
Woe to us, indeed we were in
clear air, and we were indeed
misguided, and wrong, and
oppressive. This is what
everyone says when punishment
comes, when death comes, nobody
is different in this sense. The
idea is not to believe when you
are dying. Everybody believes
when he's dying, everyone. How
can you not believe in that
situation? Everyone believes
when they're in pain, everyone
believes when they're in
discomfort, everyone calls to
Allah when they're thirsty. But
it is those who call to Allah
and repent to Allah when they
are well and healthy and alive
and satisfied. Those are the
people Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has chosen for paradise.
Because They have essentially
said with their actions, our
worship of Allah and our
gratitude to Allah essentially
exists in a timeless place. In
a vacuum. Whether we are
comfortable or uncomfortable,
whether we are hungry or
satisfied, we will always thank
Allah just the same. These are
the people Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has chosen for paradise.
May Allah make us of those